i'm brett baer i'm maria bartoromo i'm
brian kilmeade and this is the fox news
rundown
wednesday december 8th 2021 i'm lisa
brady from russia to the economy to the
border president biden's critics say the
u.s is not on the right track but is
that enough to win elections if
republicans really do want to win the
presidency and the house and senate
again what they need to do is to put
forward an agenda that merits that
support
and it's a direct and stark contrast
with what the democrats are trying to do
we speak with former new jersey governor
chris christie
i'm dave anthony a trump border policy
president biden undid is now back in
effect but not yet in one area of texas
where migrants keep surging we've seen a
huge surge of activity out here where we
are in la jolla in the rio grande valley
border agents telling us the last 72
hours have been some of the busiest
they've seen in quite some time
and i'm greg jarrett i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
russia denies that it's planning to
invade ukraine but now has tens of
thousands of troops near the border and
that was the backdrop for tuesday's
two-hour video call between presidents
biden and putin president biden was
direct and straightforward with
president putin as he always is national
security adviser jake sullivan he told
president putin directly that if russia
further invades ukraine the united
states and our european allies would
respond with strong economic measures
sullivan also says the u.s is prepared
to do things it did not do in 2014 when
sanctions were imposed after the
invasion of crimea the u.s has been in
talks with germany about russia's
nordstrom 2 pipeline recently completed
but still awaiting final approvals to
bring natural gas directly to germany
bypassing russia's traditional route
through ukraine if vladimir putin wants
to see gas flow through that pipeline he
may not want to take the risk of
invading ukraine that pipeline has been
a sore point for republicans critical of
president biden's decision earlier this
year not to try to block its completion
part of an overall approach they argue
is weak i think so far he's been rather
ineffective chris christie is the former
governor of new jersey and author of the
new book republican rescue he calls
ukraine a test he's shutting down the
keystone pipeline in america but he's
opening up the north stream pipeline to
help russia
is outrageous and it shows another
reason why he shouldn't have done that
and if you know he wants to show putin
how serious he is because tell him that
that whole thing is now open to re
renegotiation because i don't think it
should have happened in the first place
and that's where he should start but he
also should be getting personal as i
wrote in the book with putin and the
people around him and all the money
they're stealing from russia and hiding
around the world we know where a lot of
that money is and we should be freezing
those assets
the bide administration is certainly
talking about the possibility of
economic sanctions and coordination with
allies especially allies in europe
as part of either a deterrent or a
response
if there's a further escalation between
russia and ukraine
but to that point about coordinating
with allies
do you think it would be an
international crisis if russia were to
invade ukraine how confident are you the
us and its allies would step up
oh look i think they'll step up because
they understand that
further expansion of the russian empire
is a huge step backwards for the world
it's an awful betrayal of the ukrainian
people
and we're going to have to i think along
with our allies step up because you know
this kind of action in europe is not
what's in the best interest of the
united states or its allies across
western europe and eastern europe so i
do think there'll be reactions but he
should cut that off before putin does
anything to let him know
you know every every one of these
dictators
is making a cost-benefit analysis
we need to make the cost so significant
and certain
that the benefits he'll get from
invading ukraine won't be worth it for
him on balance
what about other foreign adversaries
should this administration be taking a
harder line for instance a full boycott
of the olympics in china instead of a
diplomatic boycott
i totally agree with that
i cannot imagine that we're going to go
and compete
and by competing in china
you know validate part of what's going
on in china
with people because of the religious
beliefs being shepherded into
concentration camps
and uh tortured and murdered
that kind of regime is not a regime that
we should be giving any international
credibility to by sending our wonderful
athletes over there this president
president biden is facing a number of
crises not just abroad but domestically
what do you think he needs to do to
regain
confidence from the american
people you know i don't know whether he
can at this point he's shown
his failure of confidence in afghanistan
we've got inflation over six percent
he can't control what goes on in
congress
uh we've seen some of the other problems
at the border where we have people
pouring over the border and he's not
talking about even requiring them to be
vaccinated he's talking about giving
them 450 000
per family i mean these are the kind of
things that
are
completely outrageous and so beyond what
the voters voted for him to do
when he ran for election back in 2020
and that's one of the problems with
governing contrary the brand you ran on
he ran as a moderate rather someone
who's going to bring the country
together
instead he's done exactly the opposite
he's decided he's going to be franklin
delano roosevelt too after he gets done
doing that he's going to look back and
what he's going to see is that
independents and suburban voters all
over this country have abandoned him
i know your book republican rescue
focuses on what the republican party
needs to do and looking ahead
but i'm wondering if you think the
country as a whole is as divided as
congress is right now
um and if you were president you know
how would you try to unite the parties
to get important things done
there's no question that what voters
want is campaign about the next election
not about the last election and so in
the book the emphasis we make clear is
that if republicans really do want to
win the presidency and the house and
senate again what they need to do is to
put forward an agenda that merits that
support and it's a direct and stark
contrast with what the democrats are
trying to do
now
if i were president question you know
look i think
so much of getting things done in any
legislature and i did it for eight years
in new jersey with a legislature the
opposite party is you have to build
personal relationships and personal
trust
with those members of the legislature on
both sides of the aisle to get them to
be willing to consider something you
want to do that's even the least bit
controversial but i think if if everyone
did that and empowered the right
spokesperson that there would be a real
chance that you could make some kind of
deal with those folks
the rest of the title of your book
is saving the party
from truth deniers conspiracy theorists
and the dangerous policies of joe biden
which reminds me what democrats would
say
about donald trump are you
hoping to convince any democrats or
anti-trump republicans that republicans
are not
truth deniers and conspiracy theorists
yeah and what i'm trying to convince the
republicans who are buying into some of
that stuff is that it's
counterproductive for our party and for
the country that we don't want to be
talking about the past anymore we don't
i try to go through in the book in real
detail
why the 2020 election was not stolen not
by any stretch
and that um the other conspiracy
theories that occupy some of our time
and attention are absolutely unworthy
compared to the damage that joe biden
and kamala harris are trying to do this
country right now and that's what we
need to be focused on and that's what we
need to be
absolutely working against every day by
laying out our contrary vision
for what the country should be doing and
once we do that you know i think we're
going to be on the road to winning back
the house the senate and the white house
how hard is authority for the party to
get past
the polarization related to
president trump especially if he does
end up running again
well i look it depends on what he's
saying if he continues to talk about a
stolen election in 2020 it makes it much
harder
if all of us are talking about the
future and how we would do things
differently in the country then that's
what the focus will be for voters voters
want to hear about the issues that they
care about the most and believe me no
poll is going to show you that what
voters care about the most even
republican voters in this country is the
2020 election when we have six percent
inflation we have people pouring over
the southern border when we have um
education going sideways in this country
and parents being excluded from being an
influence on their children's education
you know those are the things that
people are going to care about not what
the election results were in 2020
from that standpoint do you think that
the
january 6th committee
even though the democratic leaders of it
say it's a search for the truth
to the extent that it might just have an
overall narrative of blaming the former
president or trying to
is that going to make it more difficult
to
focus on the issues in the next
presidential election if not even in the
midterms
well look i think nancy pelosi made an
enormous mistake
by not allowing the community to be
truly bipartisan and allowing the
minority leader as they always do to
appoint whoever he saw fit for that
committee but she decided not to do that
i think she invalidated a lot of the
credibility of that committee
and i think that's a problem i do not
think that january 6 will be a
determining issue in either the 2022
election or the 2024 election
and that's not to say that i think there
was anything good about what happened on
january 6th it was awful and
reprehensible but i don't think by the
time we get to next year's election that
that will be front of mind for most
americans
what do you think will be front of mind
and as you say the book goes into a lot
of detail it's really a blueprint
for a
republican party rescue if you will but
what do you think will be front of mind
i mean right now we're still hearing a
lot about vaccine mandates
right i'm hopeful that we'll be past
that piece
i think we're going to be hearing about
rising prices
and inflation that are really
diminishing
the affordability of uh of our country i
think we're going to hear about crime
and the crime is going to be a huge
issue by next year with the type of
criminal acts that are going on around
the country and uh progressive woke
legislators who are refusing to
prosecute crimes i think you're going to
hear a great deal about education as we
heard in virginia you know we need to
make sure that we have an educational
that provides choice
for parents and involvement by parents
in in what the children are learning and
and to make sure that they're learning
those are issues right off the bat that
i think will be a large part of it in
addition to the poorest southern border
in addition to
us having uh some real stern
conversations with russia to make sure
that they do not move on ukraine
what do you say to people who say
all of those things that you just
mentioned are just republicans trying to
stir things up that um i mean obviously
the polls don't reflect this but
democrats and and the white house would
say
no things are on the right track
well
the president's approval ratings are in
the 30s so they could say they're on the
right track but wishing it doesn't make
it so the american people are in all
three parties giving this president bad
grades you know the fact is that he's
earned it because he promised to be a
moderator he was going to bring the
country together he's governed like
like an fcr democrat or even more
liberal
a lot of people who vote hopefully are
going to feel like they were taken to
the cleaners and that's not where you
want the voters to be if you want to try
to get anything done
former new jersey governor chris
christie author of the new book
republican rescue saving the party from
truth deniers conspiracy theorists and
the dangerous policies of joe biden
thank you very much for your time
thank you so much for having me on i
really appreciate it and come back
whenever you need me
[Music]
this is greg jarrett with your fox news
commentary coming up
migrants keep coming to america in a
surge republicans blame on the white
house the bite administration actually
has no adequate information to determine
the extent to which people are coming
across the border by the millions
to know whether or not they are bringing
covid or the omicron variant whatever
the case may be into the united states
of america that is completely
irresponsible and extremely dangerous
texas governor greg abbott is sparred
with the feds over stopping immigrants
and stopping wall construction arizona
attorney general mark brnovich has sued
the administration people are going to
die as a result of the cartel seizing
control of this border but one trump-era
policy that went away is back because it
was court ordered the remain in mexico
policy immigrants claiming asylum need
to wait south of the border while they
await a hearing white house press
secretary jensaki not a fan of that it
has imposed unjustifiable human costs
pulled resources and personnel away from
other priority efforts and failed to
address the root causes of a regular
irregular migration but it is in effect
again or
is it short answer absolutely not and
that's because it's not in effect where
we are bill malugen is a fox news
correspondent we caught up with him in
la jolla texas it's being slow walked
out it's starting in el paso then what
we're hearing is it's going to be moved
to brownsville and then laredo those are
going to be the first few cities in
texas where they're rolling it out now
quite frankly those are three areas
where there's not a whole lot of
activity going on the biggest hot spots
on the border are the rio grande valley
sector where we are right now and then
the del rio sector and that the
remaining mexico policy has not been
re-implemented yet in either of those
areas it doesn't mean it's not going to
be in the future it's just it hasn't yet
and we've seen a huge surge of activity
out here where we are in la jolla in the
rio grande valley border agents telling
us the last 72 hours have been some of
the busiest they've seen in quite some
time so the short answer to your
question is no we have not seen any
slowdown in activity whatsoever ever
since the announced re-implementation of
this policy all right all right help us
with the geography you go down there a
lot you you cover this area a lot so el
paso and laredo versus where you are how
far away are we talking so el paso is
incredibly far from where we are el paso
is in far west texas like right on the
border with new mexico laredo is more
kind of in the middle of texas it's a
few hours away from the del rio area we
are down in la jolla which is about an
hour away from brownsville browns mill
brownsville is a complete opposite side
of texas it's southeast texas kind of by
the gulf of mexico so el paso far west
brownsville far southeast we are kind of
in the southeast corner near brownsville
right now where we are then when you
snake your way further northwest up
texas then you're going to hit
del rio laredo eagle pass those
different cities and then why are you in
the state a bunch of different sectors
and why
where you are la jolla why in that
valley what is it that is more appealing
for migrants and people to come here
illegally there versus other places
well there's a bunch of different
factors but primarily number one there's
basically no border wall here in the hot
spots if they can just get across the
river there there's no obstruction other
than a limited border patrol force out
here that's already completely
overwhelmed you go to el paso and you'll
see i mean i lived and worked in el paso
for two years out of college they got a
lot of border wall out there it goes all
the way to hudson county and that's part
of the reason why they don't see a whole
lot of activity the way we see it out
here you go to different art different
parts of the border where there is you
know decent infrastructure with the
border wall it's not nearly as bad here
in the rio grande valley i'm looking
over my shoulder right now we have one
little half mile stretch of border wall
that started to get built under
president trump but in january it was
halted and i cannot tell you how many
times we've watched these illegal
immigrants just come across the rio
grande and then literally just walk
around this piece of metal in the field
because it's not connected to anything
so there's no resistance here
and you know rio grande valley has
always been the hot spot the city right
across from us is reynosa it's a popular
you know cartel trafficking area
but it's just it's a huge expansive area
there's a lot of easy crossing areas on
the rio grande and there's just no
there's basically no border wall here in
certain areas where they like to cross
and you talk about how busy it's been in
the last say three days weekend into
into here we are middle of the week
what
what's how much more
has the traffic been how many more of it
have come across
so i'll give you uh perspective so i
just talked to a border patrol source
out here just in the last 24 hours alone
here in the rio grande valley they've
encountered
1810 illegal immigrants they also had
179 got aways in that 24-hour period so
that's a one-day snapshot you can do the
math on that and just since october
they've already had about 105 000
encounters that's up 165 over the same
period last year so these numbers are
not slowing down they're spiking up once
again and it's not just these family
units coming across that we typically
see we're seeing a lot of runners out
here there are runners all over the
place um it's it's it's been a very very
busy morning and a very busy few days
out here all right so so we we
understand a family unit what's a runner
just someone who who who dashes and
tries to get away is that is that all
you mean yeah they're the ones who do
not turn themselves in so the difference
is the family units those are the mom's
dad's little kids you see them in all of
our video where they show up usually in
groups of dozens or sometimes hundreds
they look for border patrol they give
themselves up they want to turn
themselves in and that because they know
they'll likely be released in the
country the runners on the other hand
are typically typically going to be your
single adults who are subject to title
42 so they know if they get caught
they're going to get sent back to mexico
so they don't want to be caught either
because they know that's going to happen
maybe they have a criminal record maybe
something else but they do not turn
themselves in they're the ones who are
sneaking around wearing camouflage or
dark clothing and are running you know
they're literally running on the border
they're sprinting trying to get away
looking for areas where border patrol
agents aren't there or not and like we
just saw you know early this morning and
yesterday
a lot of where we are here in la jolla
it butts up against residential
neighborhoods and we often see these
runners take off through these homes in
these residential neighborhoods and
these guys get caught in those those
neighborhoods sometimes and it's it's
got to be pretty startling for the
families who live there that have to
always wonder if someone's going to come
flying through your backyard at any time
of the day but
the short answer to the question is the
runners are the ones who refuse to turn
themselves in and are actively trying to
get away from border patrol rather than
giving themselves up no governor greg
abbott a republican big big critic of
biden policy at the border has been
doing more of his own enforcement do you
see texas law enforcement more now in
that area or not
oh yeah i mean a state trooper literally
just drove by me as you uh asked that
question yes they are they are all they
they are all over the place i mean i
i've been i've even been pulled over
twice like you know they're they're
looking for everything out here they got
state troopers all over the roads here
um if you've got even the smallest
little infraction on your license plate
or you're speeding five miles over
they'll pull you out i mean they're
looking for human smugglers they've
surged a ton of resources out here
they've got boats all in the river state
troopers flying around all over the
place the national guard is out here
there are more texas resources than
border patrol resources um from what
i've seen and it's it's pretty wild to
think it yeah i mean it's pretty wild to
think about what would be happening down
here if texas wasn't sending its own
resources because there's absolutely not
enough border patrol personnel down here
to handle this and is texas apprehending
anyone who crosses illegally and still
putting them in that jail they had set
aside is that still happening
they are doing that up in del rio
they're not doing it down here because
they don't have a jail set up but up up
in the del rio area yes they currently
have more than 1 000 people in jail
based off criminal trespass
that sort of thing they're arresting
single adult men so
rather than just handing these guys over
to border patrol they're saying nope
we're going to do it ourselves they're
putting them in jail for criminal
trespass because they feel like border
patrol and the federal government policy
is they're just going to release some of
these people and they want to send a
message that if you come into texas
you're going to be arrested and jailed
you're not going to have the red carpet
ruled out for you and you talk to border
patrol
these agents on the federal side i mean
are they happy that texas is helping if
they have they said that i think
obviously texas is putting him in jail
and border patrol is not
the agents love having the troopers out
here they love the help they need it uh
look these agents they're very
frustrated their morale is rock bottom
they've got a job they want to be able
to do but a lot of them feel like
they've been relegated to become
babysitters and social workers just
filling out paperwork and watching
little kids and families rather a lot of
these guys want to be out on the front
lines chasing down the criminals and the
cartel members and the drugs and the
people trying to sneak across instead a
lot of them are literally just doing
paperwork all day long processing family
units and they're frustrated because the
the federal government hasn't changed
any of its policies nothing has slowed
down nothing has changed on their end
they're happy to have the troopers out
here helping them because if they
weren't there'd be a heck of a lot more
godaways and runners making it through
because border patrol cannot catch
everybody they don't catch everybody and
they certainly wouldn't have the means
to catch nearly as many people as they
are right now without the help from the
national guard and the state troopers
three months ago the big story along the
border was under a bridge in del rio
texas the word went out that the biden
administration is not going to enforce
the law and if you're from haiti come to
del rio because that means you get to
stay republican senator ted cruz from
texas that migrant camp was cleared out
amid controversy over whether border
agents hit haitians with their horse
reigns and about 13 000 of those
haitians who came here illegally were
allowed to stay
leading to reports more caravans of
haitian migrants are coming we've been
tracking the caravans a lot of them kind
of splint they all start off in
tapachula which is way in southeastern
mexico kind of near guatemala and it's a
long way to the u.s border they've got a
long way to walk a lot of them splinter
up before they get to the border however
some of them are able to find vehicle
transportation they do move further
north i don't know if you've seen but
yuma arizona is getting hit really hard
right now parts of those caravans were
trying to get there
they were planning to gather in the
mexican state of sonora which is
directly across from arizona so yuma if
you look it up on twitter right now
they've got over 3000 people in their
custody 800 people camped out waiting to
be processed they're kind of overrun
right now and the thinking is some of
those caravans have ended up in yuma
arizona right now or at least part of
them they've got a pretty serious
situation on their hands right now
because yuma's border patrol does not
have the infrastructure or the personnel
that say rio grande valley border patrol
does they're much smaller over there and
they don't have the capacity for 4 000
people showing up at once
bill you're based in l.a you've probably
spent a lot of days though in texas this
year right i mean we've talked to you
before you you seem to be down there a
lot it must be very familiar for you
there now yeah i mean i've spent
probably i think it's more than 120 days
in texas since may so far basically
almost the last seven months of my yeah
almost the last seven months i i started
at fox news in may and i've been out
here i think this is my 15th or 16th
trip and we usually do one or two week
increments so it's been quite uh
quite a few nights in texas so far
but it's a big story and when you're
really able to to dial in on a beat like
this it's it's uh it's it's pretty fun
because you start making a lot of
contacts talk to a lot of people you
start knowing places like the back your
hand so um you know it's a story that
has to be told because there's not a not
a whole lot of other media down here
telling it yeah well i don't know anyone
else closer to the story than you and so
it's good to have you and we'll hope to
dial in with you again sometime soon
bill malugen
fox correspondent based in la in la
jolla texas great to talk to you again
thank you
great to be with you thank you
[Music]
fox news radio on demand on the fox news
app download the app and just click
listen when you swipe left you can
listen to your favorite fox news talk
shows live swipe right for the latest
fox news radio newscasts on demand fox
news radio and the fox news app download
it today
subscribe to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com
it's time for your fox news commentary
jared
what's on your mind instead of getting
their deeply troubled son the
professional help he so desperately
needed james and jennifer crumley bought
him a gun
ethan crumley then used it to allegedly
murder four students at oxford high
school in michigan and wound seven
others
if there was ever a case that merited
criminal charges against the parents of
a school shooter this is it
their conduct as described by the
prosecutors is the definition of
recklessness and carelessness resulting
in death under michigan law this
constitutes involuntary murder
evidence shows the crumley's ignored
ominous warning signs that their son
ethan was psychologically unstable and
poised to commit violence they refused
demands by his school that ethan
received professional counseling they
concealed from administrators that they
had purchased him a deadly weapon and
had taken him to a firing range to
practice shooting it they knew or should
have known that their son was dangerous
and posed a threat to others
the parents were told that their son was
drawing pictures in class of killing
people and laughing about it they were
warned that ethan was searching the
internet for ammunition while in school
his mother's response in a text message
was cold and indifferent
in addition to buying ethan a nine
millimeter pistol just days before he
fired at least 30 rounds in the hallways
of his school they failed to properly
secure the gun from their 15 year old
son despite all the warning signs that
he might use it to harm others at school
the crumleys also took no precautionary
steps to determine whether ethan had
brought the gun to oxford high on the
very day they were summoned there for a
conference to discuss his aberrant
behavior
did they inform school officials they
had just bought him a gun and taught him
how to use it no
did they suggest their son be searched
or his backpack inspected
no
they insisted he remain in school that
day covering up all that they knew and
the result was deadly
jennifer crumley must have known that
her son was capable of the carnage he
inflicted minutes after he opened fire
police say she texted him quote ethan
don't do it
this is incriminating evidence of her
own complicity
in totality such grossly negligent
conduct by the parents
certainly qualifies as criminally
negligent homicide otherwise known as
manslaughter the parents should be held
accountable for their despicable
behavior
the crumleys will have their day in
court to contest the charges against
them and they are of course presumed
innocent until proven guilty
but defending the indefensible will be a
challenge
they are morally responsible for the
tragic shooting it will be up to a jury
to decide whether they are criminally
culpable
i'm greg jarrett fox news
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
from the fox news podcast network
and tim every downl fox nation host
tyrus and fox news contributor kat tim
give their hot takes explore weird
headlines and share amusing stories
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes